this episode is brought to you by Wix to
easily build your own website for free
head to wix.com slash wisecrack hey guys
michael here or as i'm known in the
office the bad boy of 19th century
Danish philosophy scholarship you
probably already know two of the things
we love rambling about most at wisecrack
are superheroes and philosophy so today
we're going to take a look at two films
that are full of superheroes and big
philosophical questions The Incredibles
and Incredibles - since the release of
The Incredibles films there has been
much digital ink spilled over its
philosophical themes with much of it
pulling around one idea namely that the
Incredibles is making an argument for
objectivism a philosophical theory
developed by novelist Eileen Rand
advocates for this reading point - the
emphasis on the exceptionalism of the
supers and the implied critique of
egalitarian society as evidence and
while we see where they're coming from
if the time comes you'll know what to do
it's in your blood we also think they're
wrong while there is undoubtedly some
Objectivist color to the film's their
true philosophical importance is the way
in which they consider the question of
power from the moral responsibility of
having superpowers - fans going insane
due to a desire for power - the power
and influence of the media these films
pose questions that are as pertinent now
as they were in 2004 and this time we
agree with you Kanye
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of The Incredibles
and of course spoilers ahead but before
we get to that a mr. incredible sighs
thank you to our sponsor Wix gives you
the super power to make beautiful robust
websites you don't have to get bitten by
a radioactive web designer anymore thank
God with utility belt that includes
custom domains enhanced security and
infinite design possibilities Wix equips
you to crank out websites in a snap that
doesn't wipe out half the universe best
part is it's absolutely free to get
started more on that at the end of the
video and now back to the Fantastic Four
I mean The Incredibles first a quick
recap in the first movie mr. Incredibles
scorned former fan buddy wants to be a
super but since he's a Normie he decides
to use technology to kill them all
instead taking on the villainous persona
name syndrome buddy plans to use mr.
incredible to optimize his own personal
death machine the Omni Droid once
perfected he plans to defeat it in
public so that society will see him as a
hero and eventually he can sell his
technology as a product so that everyone
can become super and as we all know one
super no one will be mr. incredible
feels neutered and aimless as a result
of the superhero relocation program so
what are you waiting for me too kid and
secretly returns to the superhero game
to curb an impending midlife crisis
he even questions the point of the
egalitarian spirit of Dash's elementary
school it's not a graduation is moving
from the fourth grade to the fifth grade
ceremony and psychotic they keep
creating new ways to celebrate
mediocrity but if someone is genuinely
exceptionally mad about you Bob but he
eventually comes full circle as he
realizes that his power isn't just for
feeling like a badass but instead makes
him responsible for the good of society
in this parable about power we see that
great power unchecked by great
responsibility leads to very bad things
Incredibles 2 continues this exploration
of power but shifts the focus to the
considerable influence of two media
moguls
prestige or one no not those media
moguls these ones the brother
Winston Dever is a lifelong superhero
fan who wants to use his media influence
and his seemingly endless piles of money
to repair the supers broken public image
and changed the law so that they are
legal again while his sister Evelyn
wants to use set influence to
mind-control supers into doing horrible
things thus ruining their public image
and ensuring that people don't put faith
in them ever again all right
so in order to discern why the film has
been read through the lens of
Objectivism we need to first figure out
what in the hell is objectivism the
basic tenants of Randy and objectivism
are one the ability of human reason to
gain objective knowledge of reality -
the moral aim of human life is to seek
personal happiness 3 man's being is
heroic in nature and for that free
market deregulated capitalism is the
socio-economic system most suitable for
this happy heroism so basically the
philosophy of Ron Swanson this man is a
failure he is not up to snuff his
business is failing and you're bailing
it out this is a bailout and I don't
like it
we might usually associate heroism with
those who use their powers to help
others but for Rand a captain of
industry is a better example as they are
the ones who make the world better
simply by willing their own power and
proving their superiority Randy and
superheroes don't wear capes but rather
neatly pressed suits with Italian shoes
and gold-plated cufflinks now according
to a whole bunch of writers this is just
the sort of philosophy we find in the
incredibles normal society represents
the meaningless egalitarianism which
tells us that everyone is special and
that it's bad to be exceptional the
supers represent Randy and heroes
frustrated by society's obsession with
fairness and equality only when they are
able to dawn their mask and tights are
they able to will their own power and
find happiness in their own strength but
rather than advocating for objectivism
these films shine a light on the types
of problems that come from this
inherently selfish philosophy through
the failures of both buddy and Evelyn
they explore a number of interesting
philosophical ideas
and relationship to power and
responsibility if anything the films may
be an exploration of what happens when
keeping it Rand goes wrong so let's
start by taking a look at the first film
as we mentioned many of the Incredibles
as Objectivist proponents point to the
characters frustrations with the
inhibition of their exceptional nature
Bob can't use his powers to stop mugeez
and instead professionally ruins the
lives of old ladies then there's - who
can't try out for sports lest he go all
Usain Bolt on his classmates made a
special everyone special - which is
another way of saying no and while we
see how examples of people's exceptional
nature being suppressed by society can
be read as Objectivist it ignores some
clues to the contrary first of all the
insurance company sucks
and mr. Incredibles boss is a monster
who only cares about profit tell me how
you're keeping ensure a care in the
black tell me how that's possible with
you writing checks to every area hard
luck and sow a sob story that gives you
a phone call this of course makes him an
ideal candidate for a Randy and hero but
there's no evidence that he's anywhere
close to a sympathetic character I'm not
happy Bob not happy most importantly
this reading ignores Bob's moral
eternity which can be best understood
with the help of the Greek philosopher
Aristotle whose superpower was getting
millions of undergrads to read his
boring books for thousands of years when
Bob first shoves his middle-aged body
back into his suit and gets back into
the game he does indeed exemplify the
type of selfish exceptionalism that Rand
lauded as heroic he starts to care more
about his secret superhero missions than
he does his own family selfishly
prioritizing his own power and the
pleasure it brings so if you stop the
movie after half an hour then sure mr.
incredible is an Objectivist and the
whole movie is one big ode to Iran's
philosophy but for those of us who
finished the movie we see that mr.
incredible is simply beginning a moral
journey in which he learns about the
true purpose of having great power in
his lectures on ethics Aristotle tells
us what it means to live a moral and
happy life but before giving us the
answers he warns us of some of the
common temptation
that keep us from true happiness namely
pleasure money and power coincidentally
all of these are essential components of
Objectivist happiness
much like trying to understand fit coin
Aristotle thinks our moral journey
should consist of an endless pursuit
without a seeming end after all
pleasurable activities eventually get
boring money is only for other stuff and
never really makes us happy and power is
often dependent on factors outside our
control mr. incredible seems to fall
into a devil's three-way of moral
temptation as his super secret superhero
activities bring him pleasure
make him feel powerful and throw some
extra O's in his bank account along the
way like a good Randy and hero in this
false happiness he's experiencing
pleasure from his own power which is
sort of like masturbating to a picture
of yourself and according to a friend of
mine you can't come back from that now
of course mr. incredible is only drawn
back into his super self via the
trickery of his old fan buddy now acting
his syndrome and while buddy wanted
nothing more than to be mr. Incredibles
faithful sidekick when he was younger
this fixation on Power has turned his
fandom into a near psychotic obsession
after all I am your biggest fan buddy
has structured his happiness and his
moral goals around this pursuit of power
he wants power so badly that he needs to
destroy the supers to prove to himself
and the world that he has an ultimate
sort of power and this does not end well
as at one point buddy doesn't seem to
give a crap when mr. incredible almost
kills his assistant Mirage that sounds a
little dark for you now go ahead if she
was an Objectivist before this encounter
she's throwing out her copy of Atlas
Shrugged afterwards on the flip side
when mr. Incredibles pursuit of personal
power puts his family in harm's way he
realizes that his power is only moral
when it's actively used in the service
of others I'm not strong strong enough
and this will make you strong yes no
that's what this is some sort of workout
I can't lose you again
I can't whether these others be his
family or the innocent citizens of metro
Ville this stands in stark contrast with
rands insistence that one's personal
happiness leads to the greatest good
about my life and my love of it but I
will never live for the sake of another
man nor ask another man to live for mine
and it's this that distinguishes buddy
from mr. incredible in Incredibles - it
seems as if a couple of Objectivist
captains of industry might just be the
saviors of supers everywhere as the
second film finds The Incredibles both
broke and without government protection
these two hyper capitalists Winston and
Evelyn Dever are set to make everything
better with their financial resources
and media influence for a moment it
seems that the powers of industry might
just save the day and Randian terms that
Dever siblings are titans of industry
ready to get what they want
ie fulfill their own happiness via the
most powerful force in modern society
the media as a childhood superhero nerd
all grown up Winston wants to use his
media influence to literally change the
law so that he can get what he wants
which is a world full of cool
superheroes to idolize and though Evelyn
might initially seem on board with her
brothers plans she intends to use her
tech Empire to make sure that supers go
extinct as she has spent her entire life
blaming them for the loss of her father
it's revealed in the film that when
burglars broke into their home Evelyn
and Winston's father waited on two
supers to save him but they never showed
up and he was murdered for Evelyn her
father's reliance on the supers is
indicative of an inability to take
responsibility for one's own life and
actions it's sort of like how all of us
who grew up with spellcheck can't spell
calendar or definitely to save our lives
Evelyn's desire for self-reliance is
very Randian but it's not so kosher that
she wants to stifle the exceptionalism
of others but while all of these shiny
titans of industry are spending billions
to get what they want
the villains screen slaver exposes the
dark power of screens this resentment of
superheroes and their broader effect on
society leads Evelyn to create screen
slaver whose mission is expressed in a
strikingly poignant manifesto
superheroes are part of your brainless
desire to replace
to experience with simulation you don't
talk you watch talk shows you don't play
games you watch game shows travel
relationships risk every meaningful
experience must be packaged and
delivered to you to watch at a distance
if much of this sounds eerily true of
our contemporary relationship to
technology it's because it is before we
know that Evelyn is screen slaver she
has a conversation about the ills of the
modern era with Helen in which Helen
agrees with her which of us has the
greater influence which side of me are
you asking the believer or the cynic the
cynic would say selling is more
important because the best sellers have
the most buyers it doesn't matter what
you're selling it only matters what
people buy now while a disciple of Rann
might argue that our present digital age
has led to a capitalist utopia in which
the right algorithms can lead to massive
wealth for the exceptional few the
movies explore the effect that this
entertainment driven media has on our
humanity to better understand this we
can turn to 19th century Danish
philosopher Soren Kierkegaard who at
times was the screen slaver of his day
Kierkegaard was worried that the modern
media which at that point was the dawn
of print media was creating a world
devoid of passion in which reading about
the interesting lives of others was
thought to be equivalent to living an
interesting life oneself in a line that
makes me relatively convinced that he
had access to time travel and spent an
afternoon reading sponsored content on
Instagram Kierkegaard said about his own
age that while a revolutionary age is an
age of action the present age is an age
of advertisement and publicity nothing
happens but there is instantly publicity
about it for both screen slaver and
Kierkegaard the media distorts our
relationship to powerful people as
rather than lead us to imitating them in
our own lives and activities we settle
and become mere spectators Kierkegaard
was worried that this would make 19th
century Europe devoid of passion and
individuality of course this doesn't end
well for Evelyn and eventually the
superheroes all come together and use
their collective power for good
both stopping Evelyn's plan and in the
process restoring the world's faith in
the goodness of
superheroes notably Winston is pushed to
action during the final act not just
using his massive resources to change
the world for the better but by actually
risking his own life to save the lives
of others just like in the first film we
see that true heroics isn't just flexing
one's own power it's about doing the
right thing at the right time to pull
one more example from Aristotle he
thought that justice was completed
virtue as true justice is working for
the good of another and in this way both
films show that true heroes exhibit this
type of justice as their power is at its
most virtuous when it's used in service
of others and we have a final critique
of Randian thought and violets final
words during Evelyn's arrest
well I'm sorry she's rich and would
probably get no more than a slap on the
wrist because at the end of the day
Metro Ville is like our own world and
access to wealth is the ultimate
superpower and while Oh Randy an
Objectivist would enthusiastically agree
violet is pointing out the fundamental
injustice in this type of system so
there you have it what some see as a
pair of films of the Randian slant are
in fact asking crucial questions about
power responsibility and the forces in
our world that have power over our
attention and imagination and just in
case you still need to hold on to some
sort of objective truth just listen to
what mr. incredible has to say about
math why would they change math yes it's
math math or if not share your own
truths with the world by creating a free
website with Wix click here to get
started building an easy
professional-looking website right here
thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]